alors vous êtes venus pour parler
d'optimisme est évidemment moi j'ai
cherché une question qui puisse
correspondre à ce thème pour ouvrir
dignement notre soirée donc voilà celle
que je vous propose
qui parmi vous à penser aujourd'hui à sa
mort et s'était pas levé la main je dis
bien à sa mort pas à la mort en général
et pas non plus à la mort de votre
belle-mère parce que ça rendrait
l'exercice un peu trop facile bon alors
rassurez vous c'est normal que vous ne
soyez pas très nombreux sauf un peu de
ce côté là à répondre par l'affirmative
à ma question
en effet en règle générale on ne pense
pas à sa propre mort
évidemment comme dans toute règle il ya
toujours des exceptions
donc si on a manqué de se faire écraser
ou peut-être pire encore si on a voulu
en finir après avoir écouté le dernier
titre de booba il est possible qu'on ait
pensé à sa mort
pour le reste c'est peu le cas imaginez
d'ailleurs quelle serait votre terreur
si vous pensiez continûment à votre
propre mort c'est pourquoi notre cerveau
crée des peurs secondaire pour nous
détourner de notre angoisse
existentielle de la mort par exemple
est-ce que je vais me retrouver au
chômage
est-ce que je vais finir ma vie tout
seul ou tout aussi angoissant est ce que
mon chien va aimer ces nouvelles
croquettes pour ma part je ne ressens
plus et peur depuis que j'ai rencontré
ma mort qu'elle est devenue ma meilleure
amie et qu'elle a changé ma vie
il faut dire que je commence à bien la
connaître en effet j'ai failli mourir
quatre fois ma première rencontre avec
la mort remonte à 2001 et à un accident
d'alpinisme à chamonix
ce jour là pourtant tout aurait dû
d'autant mieux se passer que mon copain
guide et moi n'avions pas pu grimper en
haute altitude
nous nous étions donc rabattu sur une
journée d'entraînement en moyenne
altitude et qui dit moyenne altitude
en théorie dit moindre danger que la
haute altitude
nous avions sélectionné une phase
rocheuse d'une centaine de mètres de
hauteur que nous avons escalader est
descendu cette fois dans la journée et
le clin d'oeil du destin a voulu que mon
accident intervienne au départ de la
dernière descente en rappel de la
journée c'est à dire à quelques minutes
d'être hors de danger
alors en descente en rappel on se laisse
glisser le long d'une corde mais est on
réguler sa vitesse de descente avec un
petit ustensile métallique un descendeur
mais on n'est pas réellement attaché à
la corde et encore moins à la paroisse
donc la moindre erreur ne pardonne pas
or ce jour-là je ne commets pas une pas
deux mais trois erreurs la première fut
liée au fait que nous allions quitté la
paroisse et que donc j'avais récupéré
pas mal de matériel sur celle ci et
lorsque je m'aperçus que ce matériel
alem gêné pour réaliser ma descente
j'étais déjà en position de rappel comme
sur ce dessin est donc en position
dangereuse et l'erreur que je commis fut
de vouloir ranger ce matériel dans cette
position de rappel au lieu de
remonter au piton un mètre au dessus et
de ranger son matériel en toute quiétude
et en toute sécurité et ce qui devait
arriver mais que je n'avais pas prévu
arriva c'est à dire que je fis une
fausse manoeuvre en rangeant mon
matériel et que je tombais la tête la
première en arrière dans le vide alors
petit problème
j'étais à 50 mètres du sol ce qui
évidemment ne garantit pas un
atterrissage super paisible et c'est là
que la deuxième erreur que j'avais
commis ce jour-là pris toute son
importance
en effet j'étais en moyenne altitude et
je n'avais donc pas pris toutes les
mesures de sécurité que j'aurais prises
en haute altitude et en particulier je
n'avais pas confectionné sur la corde
le noeud qui aurait permis de stopper ma
chute
instantanément ainsi donc quand j'entame
cette chute jeu n'est a priori pas de
moyen de m'arrêter
et c'est là que j'ai eu la troisième
idée brillante de la journée vous savez
en fait quand on est crétin voilà ça
passe pas en une journée
alors évidemment moi dans mon cas là ça
a failli passer pour toujours mais papa
pas de la meilleure manière qui soit
donc ma troisième idée brillante a été
de maths de saisir la corde à pleines
mains pour essayer de m'arrêter
alors c'est l'erreur que je me reproche
le moins étant donné qu'elle est le
fruit d'un réflexe de survie problème
c'est que la corde défilé à toute
vitesse ou d'ailleurs plutôt c'est moi
qui défilait à toute vitesse et que du
coup lorsque je saisis la corde à
pleines mains la corde me brûle a
tellement les mains qu'elle en rouge à
leschères rendant celle-ci inutilisable
pour la suite de ma chute et mon
sauvetage d'autant plus improbable
alors vous vous dites voilà
au contraire de ce dessin ça sent
probablement mauvais pour moi à ce
moment-là je vous le confirme j'ai eu un
peu le temps d'ailleurs de me rendre
compte et ans et que j'ai chuté comme ça
pendant vingt-cinq mètres et vous vous
dites aussi mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pour que tu sois là et que tu es
le plaisir de partager cette expérience
avec nous et donc là il s'est passé
quelque chose qui va vous donner là
probablement la plus grande leçon de
cette soirée t'aide à savoir ne pas être
une fashion victim permet d'éviter
d'être une victime tout court en effet
j'aime portait des vêtements beaucoup
trop grand et je portais donc ce jour-là
un t-shirt beaucoup trop vent et le
t-shirt ce coin ça entre la corde et le
petit descendeur arrêtant la course de
la corde et par là même ma chute
la brutalité de ses tares et occasionna
plusieurs blessures dont quelques
fractures de vertèbres mais j'étais
vivant et heureux de l'être
au delà de ses conséquences physiques il
eut également une conséquences
psychiques sous la forme de la
découverte de ma mortalité celle ci fût
exacerbée quelques années plus tard
lorsque je subis trois arrêts cardiaques
en l'espace d'une semaine dont je
réchappaient de nouveaux miraculeusement
mon épouse aime à dire que mon ange
gardien ne rechigne pas à la tâche et je
crois qu'elle a ses raisons lors donc de
chaque arrêt cardiaque
je perdis connaissance et l'une de ses
pertes de connaissance fut plus
spectaculaire que les autres car elle
intervint alors que j'étais au volant de
ma voiture et je venais en plus de
parcourir 300 km sur l'autoroute
alors heureusement la reine intervint
pas sur l'autoroute
mais quelques minutes plus tard sur une
route de forêt où je circulais
logiquement moins rapidement
je perdis connaissance la voiture
continua sa route tout seul et fini son
parcours dans un muret cette fois ci
sans grande gravité
ces différentes rencontres avec ma mort
ont logiquement modifié ma vision de la
vie et en particulier mon rapport avec
deux peur la peur de la mort d'une part
la peur du vide
d'autre part en confrontant avec ma mort
mais accidents ont rendu inutiles les
dérivatifs ses peurs secondaire que
j'évoquais dans mon propos liminaire qui
ont précisément pour objectif de nous
détourner de notre mortalité dans mon
cas ils étaient devenus inutiles et ce
changement a provoqué une inversion de
mon rapport à la peur avant probablement
comme chacun d'entre vous lorsque
j'essayais de me rassurer
consciemment j'avais toujours une petite
voix à l'arrière de ma tête dans mon
inconscient qui me rappelait l'origine
de mon inquiétude aujourd'hui mon
inconscient me rassure en permanence en
me disant qu aux côtes a failli mourir
quatre fois qu'est ce que tu veux qu'il
t'arrive
alors mon inconscient me parlait un peu
familièrement vous l'excuser mais il est
vrai qu'on a vécu des choses un peu
ensemble et donc on peut le comprendre
mais si je n'ai plus peur de mourir
en revanche j'ai peur de ne pas vivre en
d'autres termes j'ai peur du vide j'ai
peur du néant de l'absence de vie pas
évident dans lequel je suis tombé à
chamonix naturellement mon cerveau a été
reprogrammé par mes différents accidents
pour vivre chaque minute à fond et cette
reprogrammation a été tellement
puissante qu'elle a effacé quasiment
tous mes souvenirs
ainsi lorsque mon épouse et moi dit non
avec mes parents octogénaires et qu'ils
évoquent des souvenirs de ma jeunesse
le commensal qui est atteint de la
maladie d'alzheimer n'est pas celui que
vous pourriez croire de même
j'aborde chaque journée comme si elle
pouvait être la dernière
il faut dire que j'ai connu quatre
journées qu'on failli être la dernière
il n'ya plus du coup pour moi deux
journées sans importance
chaque jour est une petite vie à mes
yeux je n'ai chaque matin j'essaye de
tirer le maximum de ma journée et je
meurs
le soir alors qu'elle est ma recette si
j'ose dire
pour profiter ainsi de chaque minute et
de chaque journée elle est assez simple
finalement
elle consiste à toujours essayé de me
remettre en question
le challenge et apprendre progresser à
mes yeux se remettre en permanence en
question c'est essayer de vivre
plusieurs vies parce que on ne cesse
d'évoluer se remettre en question c'est
aussi répondre à deux de mes objectifs
le premier qui correspond au sens que je
donne désormais à ma vie depuis mai
accident et d'essayer de devenir la
meilleure version possible de moi même
en quelque sorte l'homme que mon chien
crois que je suis je vous rassure c'est
le seul que j'arrive à tromper pourquoi
je veux devenir la meilleure version
possible de moi même parce que j'ai eu
une chance extraordinaire
rendez vous compte que peu de gens déjà
ont le droit à une deuxième chance
moi j'ai eu une deuxième une troisième
une quatrième une cinquième chance et
une chance quelque part c'est d'abord
une responsabilité
donc j'essaye d'en être digne et de la
mériter et mon deuxième objectif qui est
le corollaire du premier correspond
aussi
à cette vision mon deuxième objectif
c'est d'essayer également de donner la
meilleure contribution possible aux
communautés auxquelles j'appartiens à ce
sujet bob dylan a chanté dans un de ses
célèbres morceaux que celui qui n'est
pas occupé à naître est occupé à mourir
en me remettant en permanence en
question j'essaye de toujours être
occupés à naître ou à renaître dans mon
cas
vous le voyez mes rencontres avec ma
môme ont largement émancipée j'aborde la
vie aujourd'hui
comme c'est non voyants qui compensent
leur cécité en maximisant leur autre
sens j'ai eu la chance de voir la mort
en face et de ne plus jamais être mort
de peur alors à ce sujet vous connaissez
peut-être la fable inventée par le
philosophe anglais chesterton il y
raconte l'histoire de deux jeunes
garçons qui chacun peuvent réaliser un
voeu l'un décide de devenir un géant
l'autre un lilliputien d'un cm de
hauteur et le paradoxe veut que alors
que le géant peut parcourir aisément
l'ensemble de la planète
il s'ennuie très vite parce qu'ils ne
trouvent rien à sa mesure
au contraire le lilliputien ne quitte
jamais le jardin de sa maison où la
moindre taupinière prend les allures
d'une montagne merveilleuse depuis mai
accident je suis devenu ce lilliputiens
et d'ailleurs c'est probablement la
raison pour laquelle on m'a jugé sur ce
tabouret afin que je puisse vous voir
je suis ce lilliputiens parce que
désormais j'envisage chaque expérience
même la plus anodine avec émerveillement
avant j'étais le spectateur de ma vie je
prêtais attention au moment de plaisir
qu'elle pouvait me procurer désormais je
suis l'acteur de ma vie je n'y prête pas
attention mais je la vis avec une
intention le sens que je lui donne est
plus que du plaisir j'y trouve du
bonheur alors vous pourriez me le dire
et vous seriez est totalement légitime à
me poser cette question
oui mais christophe cette vision de la
vie ça marche bien quand tout va bien
dans ta vie mais ça fonctionne beaucoup
moins bien quand les choses vont mal
or je crois que précisément c'est le
contraire parce que c'est quand les
choses vont mal dans votre vie que vous
êtes confrontés à des situations à des
expériences qui sont au mieux anodine
plus souvent difficile et que votre
capacité à aborder
chacune de vos expériences avec
émerveillement ou avec enthousiasme et
la plus bénéfique pour vous je parle
d'expérience parce qu'il se trouve que
je relève au sens propre et au sens
figuré d'une greffe osseuse à la colonne
vertébrale
conséquence lointaine de mon accident
d'alpinisme greffe à la suite de
laquelle j'ai été couché pendant près
d'un an 24 heures sur 24
à ce sujet einstein aurait dit qu il y a
deux manières de vivre sa vie l'une est
de ne rien considérer comme un miracle
l'autre et 2 to considéré comme un
miracle et dans cette optique pour
conclure je voudrais vous proposer trois
réflexions sous la forme de trois
questions relatives à trois temps
votre existence le temps long tout
d'abord est ce que vous vivez votre vie
en spectateur ou en acteur en lui
donnant un sens le temps intermédiaire
ensuite est-ce que vous envisagez
chacune de vos journées comme la
dernière et le temps court
enfin est-ce que vous considérez chaque
moment même le plus anodin avec
enthousiasme
j'espère en tout cas que c'est au moins
le cas pour celui que nous vivons
ensemble en ce moment alors pourquoi ces
questions sont elles si importante parce
que s'il est une chose que la vie m'a
appris c'est que c'est en nous et nulle
part ailleurs que nous trouvons le
bonheur et je vous souhaite dans ce
domaine d'être plus doués que moi ce qui
ne devrait pas être difficile et de ne
pas avoir à vivre un éventuel flirte
avec votre mort pour découvrir en vous
peut-être grâce aux trois questions que
je vous ai suggéré des sources
insoupçonnées d'optimisme et de bonheur
merci